est ce qu'on a bien deux mécaniciens
avoir mangé trop de chimie pendant une
réparation de voitures non on s'est
posés ainsi si c'était sur rmc
découverte on a découvert un génie du
sans-gêne le gall va avoir un petit
souci n'a pas réussir à se retenir je
crois surtout qu'il n'en a rien à faire
de se retenir regarder et surtout
écouter le doublage est exceptionnel
regarde votre d'emploi c'est pour les
amateurs servirait de papier toilette
il a une double épaisseur côté plats
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur extérieur
ça aussi c'est à l'extérieur
excuse moi j'aime bien me voilà alors
c'est franchement c'est sympa mais alors
est ce matin il ya eu un autre petit peu
tout pendant l'interview des 4 vérités
sur france 2 n'en mais je vous le dis
très allemand oui j'ai un genre
détecteur regarde ni chair à quel prix
vous vendez les masques jetables dans
vos magasins
le prix de référence chez nous
aujourd'hui c'est 4 euros 95 la boîte de
50 masques vous en avez vendu combien
depuis quelques mois et 4 euros 95 la
boîte de 50 masques
alors on veut dire j'ai le jus l'oreille
pétales je veux dire ça va demander
spécialistes majeur à gaza je pense que
c'est du direct
je pensais en live alors justement
maintenant la cassette a dit vous êtes
un habitué des flatulences chez nous et
bien sûr et il va y avoir jeudi une de
rendre à une grande race sera
exceptionnel ce sera le cinquième
épisode et benjamin castaldi était
chauffeur vtc
regardez il a il a piégé des clients
regarder la kpop hop hop hop hop au long
coma s'en fout nouvelle saison
[Applaudissements]
ces nouveaux horaires
vraiment ce n'est donc la solidité en
femme aujourd'hui